[Applause]
[Music]
Marketing CEO Brian Halligan placed the
winning bid at an auction here in New
York the 1.9 million dollar price tag
after a buyers feet makes wolf one of
the most expensive guitars ever sold a
guitar and Gerry and the Grateful Dead
have had a great impact on my life and
I'm thrilled to hone a little piece of
it the guitars previous owner decided to
sell off the rock relic and donate the
proceeds to the Southern Poverty Law
Center an organization dedicated to
fighting hate groups
and keeping in the dead community's
spirit of sharing an anonymous charity
matched the guitars purchase price
netting more than three and a half
million dollars for the Law Center
[Music]
and we are really pleased to have Wolff
here in the studio with us this morning
what are they most exciting guests we've
added a long time plus our Lynette
preferred Z's Charlotte domained /
Shetty thank you so much for a minute
what a thrill this is this is the best
in terms of auction price did this
exceed your expectations
it did with the combined matching funds
the most money ever for any instrument
ever sold it was a wonderful night in
the spirit of supporting Southern
Poverty which I have to say at this time
in our history we need that group more
than ever and it was just a joyful night
20 great musicians performed into the
small hours at the Brooklyn Bowl with a
funky terrific venue here in New York it
was as good as it got what's amazing is
how this object carries with it so much
meaning Dead fans across the country
across the world have some they can feel
something in that guitar given the
relationship that a lot of dead fans
have to the band well-dressed men and
women came to me on their hands and
knees begging just to put their pinky on
this for a second yeah I can imagine
you said oh we're happy to put our
pinkies on fifteen years ago it sold for
$800,000 alright are Lynette and your
thank you so much